der Herrscher der Kiew in wenigen Tagen
einnehmen wollte wurde 16 Monate später
fast in Moskau von Söldner Truppen
überrollt Putin im Showdown mit
wagnerchef briochin die Ereignisse vom
Samstag in Russland sind beispiellos
ziemlich unübersichtlich und zeugen von
gefährlicher Instabilität der Putsch
wurde verhindert die Aufständischen
gehen straffrei aus Belarus Machthaber
Lukaschenko kommt dabei dem russischen
Präsidenten zu Hilfe was bedeutet das
für den Kriegsverlauf in der Ukraine und
auch für unsere Sicherheitslage nach dem
putzversuch bröckelt Putins macht unser
Thema in der Phönix Runde
[Musik]
ihr habt die verfassungsmäßige Ordnung
beschützt so wie Menschen leben die
Sicherheit und die Freiheit unserer
Bürger ihr habt unsere Heimat vor einer
Erschütterung beschützt faktisch habt
die einen Bürgerkrieg beendet
russlands Präsident heute bei einer Rede
vor Vertretern der Nationalgarde und der
Sicherheitskräfte schönen guten Abend
aus Berlin ja reden wir über diese
Ereignisse in Russland mit diesen Gästen
Gesine dürrenblut Journalistin ehemalige
Russland Korrespondentin für den
Deutschlandfunk und Autorin des Buches
jenseits von Putin und herzlich
willkommen Alexander Lippmann Professor
für Politikwissenschaft mit Schwerpunkt
Osteuropa und Russland an der Freien
Universität in Berlin in Russland
geboren und aufgewachsen ich begrüße
Andreas heinemann-grüder Professor für
Politikwissenschaften an der Universität
Bonn auch Schwerpunkt Russland und
Ukraine ist konfliktforscher und der hat
in den 80er Jahren in Moskau studiert
zugeschaltet ist uns Wolfgang Richter
ober ST ade Berater im genferzentrum für
Sicherheitspolitik zuvor war er tätig
unter anderem bei der OSZE im
Verteidigungsministerium und der UN mit
dem Schwerpunkt Rüstungskontrolle
Herr Lippmann wenn man sagt oder wir
haben es eben gehört Putin hat gesagt
ein Bürgerkrieg wurde verhindert stehen
wir sozusagen gerade am Anfang vom Ende
des System Putins ich glaube am Anfang
davon Ende von System Putin stehen wenn
mindestens seit anderthalb Jahren aber
das Problem ist nur wie lange es noch
dauern wird die jetzige Situation hat
Putin tatsächlich am Ende unter
Kontrolle gebracht aber es hat auf jeden
Fall Effekte für sein Regime die wir
noch lange gemerkt werden
was denken sie ja Heinemann hätte
pregorien der wagner-chef die Macht
gehabt Putin zu stürzen
ich glaube es war nicht ein Putsch es
war eine Meuterei es war eine Reaktion
da drauf dass
der Verteidigungsminister Scholl Guhr
die wagnergruppe entmachten wollte das
angeblich Angriffe auf Wagner
Militärlager gegeben hat er wollte
zeigen dass er als furchtiger russischer
Musik das nicht mit sich machen lässt er
wollte vielleicht auch zeigen dass es
Solidarität unter einigen oder Sympatien
unter einigen Offizieren gibt aber es
bestand nie das Ziel den Kennel
einzunehmen und insofern sollte man das
eher als Meuterei oder als Aufruhr aber
nicht als putzversuch bezeichnen
was denken Sie wie viel im Rückhalt hat
Putin jetzt noch in der russischen
Bevölkerung haben sehen sie ihn als
geschwächter durch oder gerade noch mal
besonders gestärkt weil er ist ja
niedergeschlagen hat oder wie auch immer
den Aufstand oder versucht wie man das
bewertet ich denke auch das war kein
Putsch gegen Putin sondern das war ein
erster Linie eine Flucht nach vorne um
den eigenen das das eigene herrschen
über seine Truppe und so weiter zu
sichern denn privaten zum Schluss mit
dem Rücken zur Wand und das war eine
Flucht nach vorne und er ist dann weiter
gegangen möglicherweise als er
eigentlich vorhatte um sich gehört zu
verschaffen bei Putin und war
möglicherweise dann auch ganz froh dass
er dann kurz vor Moskau noch ein Ausweg
aufgezeigt bekommen hat zu Ihrer Frage
nach Putin Stärke oder Schwäche ich
glaube da ist wir sollten uns vor ruhig
full thinking wirklich schützen und
Hüten
es ist klar geworden dass es
Schwachstellen gibt in Russland im
Staatsapparat Putin hat nicht den
gesamten Staatsapparat hinter sich nicht
den Machtapparat sonst wäre das nicht
möglich gewesen das Flieger so
durchläuft aber so wie es jetzt aussieht
versucht er alles zu übertünchen
erstellt das alles ganz anders da also
als großer Sieg und
wunderbares Meisterwerk von ihm selber
da ist heute also ja großes großes
Theater im Gange in Moskau und ist ich
schließe nicht aus dass er da wirklich
erstmal vorerst gestärkt rauskommt aus
der Sache
Richter wie sehen Sie es als Militär
wenn da eine ja eine Privatarmee oder
wie man sie nennen will eine Armee
sozusagen nicht offiziell zum russischen
Militär gehört wenn die auf die
Hauptstadt dazu marschiert also geht es
eigentlich ohne Verbündete macht Apparat
ja das hängt davon ab was ich
gedacht habe er hat natürlich im Grunde
genommen auch das System Putin
herausgefordert natürlich galt seinen
Ärger vor allem dem
Verteidigungsminister Scholl und dem dem
Chef des Generalstabs also der Rassismus
natürlich weiß klar dass er damit auch
viele angesprochen hat gerade
frontgruppen angesprochen hat die
unzufrieden sind möglicherweise mit der
Art der Kriegsführung aber er hat am
Ende in sein doch sehr Wüsten einlassen
die er da über Twitter oder sonstige
Kanäle Telegramm natürlich verbreitet
hat dann auch indirekt Putin angegriffen
indem er nämlich die Gründe für die
Kriegsführung in Frage gestellt hat und
damit hat er ganz eindeutig rote Linien
überschritten im übrigen zeigt es sich
was passieren kann wenn das macht
Monopol nicht beim Start bleibt sondern
geteilt wird und dir doch einen Kämpfe
entstehen und das ist das Ergebnis er
wollte sich natürlich nicht ein
Gemeinden lassen in die Idee das ist ja
vom verteilungsminister so vorgeschlagen
worden und am Ende sah er nur die Flucht
nach vorne die Frage ist was es wirklich
war ich stimme den zu die gesagt haben
es ist kein Putsch eigentlich gewesen
sondern eine Rebellion eine militäre
Region und die hat sich ja formal gar
nicht gegen Putin gerichtet sondern
gegen die Militärführung ob er
Verbündete hatte oder angenommen hat
dass er Verbündete auch im Militär hat
kann man nur spekulieren natürlich frage
ich mich auch warum ihm kein Widerstand
geleistet wurde z.B in Rostock am
donnern oder auch später dann also
durchkam überall gibt es Hauptquartiere
also der Militärbezirk ist in Rostock am
donnern und aber auch eine Armee
Kommando innerlich und das bedeutet
schon dass man die Frage stellen muss
wieso haben hat man dort nicht reagiert
unterm Strich seid
aber man sollte nicht jetzt in den
Glauben verfallen dass die Masse der
russischen Bevölkerung
vielleicht auf der Straße
aber also er hat ja gesagt wir sind
losgegangen und Protest zu demonstrieren
nicht um die Obrigkeit zu stürzen das
würde ja ihre These der ausstoßen Herr
Heinemann aber trotzdem war ihm nicht
klar was das bedeutet wenn wenn seine
Truppen da losging was das er fällt ja
damit seinem alten Kumpel Putin komplett
in den Rücken
in das System das Putin errichtet hat
hatte bestand ja daran dass es immer die
Konkurrenz zwischen verschiedenen
Sicherheitsorganen gab also Putin hat
sich nicht immer auf einen allein
verlassen sondern konnte die ständig
gegeneinander ausspielen und die
Konkurrenz machte pregorian und Wagner
natürlich
und und Putin hat die natürlich auch
genutzt um um seine eigene uns
Zufriedenheit mit Schalke und grassimov
und anderen oberkommandieren dann zum
Ausdruck zu bringen und da dachte
vielleicht also gerade weil das System
auf dieser Konkurrenz der
Sicherheitsapparate auch basiert und sie
Kompetenzen nie ganz klar abgegrenzt
sind deswegen werde ich sozusagen aus
dem Schach spielen nicht rausgezogen der
Effekt jetzt ist ja das Putin in eine
viel größere Abhängigkeit von und die
rassimo auf Gerät weil er eigentlich
nicht mehr in der Gegengewicht dagegen
aufbauen kann und das zweite ist also
die Gruppe Wagner aber auch ein paar
andere haben natürlich auch elementare
Funktionen in diesem Krieg gespielt
schon 2014/15 und da dachte also diese
Funktionen die sind nicht so leicht von
den regulären Streitkräften zu
übernehmen also die mobilen
unterscheidet die von den regulären
Streitkräften wo sind die da anders also
das eine ist wahrscheinlich dass sie
flexibler einsetzbar sind dass sie auch
sozusagen
auftragskommando haben und insofern
nicht von diesen Hierarchien so abhängig
sind dass sie sehr viel Kampf Erfahrung
haben dass sie Disziplinen haben dass
die Opfer von Wagner nicht sichtbar sind
in der Bevölkerung die werden frontner
sozusagen
beerdigt die sind kein es führt nicht zu
Unzufriedenheit in den Regionen das sind
alles Faktoren die dann Rolle spielen
dann sind sie sehr gut ausgebildeten
Straßen kam dann haben sie als sagen
nicht das Problem dass man Truppen von
hinten braucht also bei den regulären
Truppen gibt's Leute die da andere von
der Desertion abhalten das Problem hatte
Wagner gelöst indem sie ein paar Mal
öffentlich sozusagen dieser Türe
umgebracht hatten damit war dieses
ziplin sichergestellt und das weitere
war dass sie eben diese Rekrutierung in
den strafgefangenenlagern vorgenommen
hatten
da ist jetzt was was offensichtlich das
regulären Militär auch praktizieren will
aber das untergräbt eigentlich die
Organisationskultur in einem Militär
wenn man verurteilte Mörder da aufnimmt
also da gab es ein paar Funktionen
dachte so leicht bin ich nicht ersetzbar
also Putin brauchte oder braucht ihn
auch jetzt noch im in diesem Krieg ich
glaube schon also ich glaube schon war
für Putin zumindest ein bequemes
Instrument das zu einem gewissen
Zeitpunkt eingesetzt wurde als der Krieg
angefangen hat und das haben wir jetzt
gerade in den Kämpfen um bachmut sehr
klar beobachtet auch mit und das würde
ich besonders betonen sehr hohen
Opferbereitschaft von Wagner Truppen die
zum Teil daran lag dass da gerade die
ehemaligen die aus dem Gefängnis
gewissen rekrutierten Soldaten gekämpft
haben und Wagner hat da ein bachmut die
Erfolge zum Teil durch extrem große
Zahlen der gefallenen Soldaten erreicht
und sich beschwert dass es zu wenig
Munition gab ich beschwere sie zu wenig
Munition gab und da kommen wir dann auch
auf den Punkt den wir schon angesprochen
haben die ständigen Kämpfe in der
russischen Militär im russischen
Staatsapparat in den prikorcheln sich
aber auf eine etwas andere Weise
verhalten hat als die anderen nämlich
deutlich offener deutlich
medienwirksamer und zum Teil auch
deutlich kritische auch im Bezug auf
indirekt Putin selbst es gab vor einigen
Monaten diese komische
Andeutung über einen Opa der Glaube dass
alles gut ist aber in der Wirklichkeit
und dann kommt ein russisches sehr grobe
Schimpfwort und das Wort Opa wird auch
sehr oft für Putin verwendet das heißt
es ist eigentlich also prikotin hat
immer die Grenzen getestet dessen was er
machen darf und so mega Putin
geschrieben hat solange Putin das
akzeptiert hat ginge es und da ging es
ja offensichtlich jetzt an diesem
Samstag soweit putin hatte
das ganz wichtig ist also die
wagnergruppe ist ja an noch viel
weiteren viel mehr Orten aktiv für die
kämpfen nicht nur in der Ukraine sondern
sie hat auch in Syrien gekämpft sie ist
in Afrika und da spielt sie eben eine
sehr sehr wichtige Rolle auch politisch
aber auch sicherheitsmäßig geopolitisch
für Russland weil sie da eben zum
Beispiel in der Zentralafrikanischen
Republik oder in Mali auch in Libyen
eine Zeit lang
die Drecksarbeit gemacht hat oder das
getan hat wozu die russische Armee die
reguläre russische Armee nicht fähig war
oder nicht willens war und da hat auch
Außenminister darauf jetzt schon
angedeutet dass in der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik und in
Mali weiter er hat glaube ich allgemein
formuliert Militär Ausbilder tätig sein
sollen aber wir wissen das sind
Angehörige der wagnergruppe insofern ist
es nicht nur so dass
das von Putin abhängig ist sondern Putin
braucht auch jeden und das wird die
Gosch ihn auch gewusst haben und wissen
dann ist es doch umso merkwürdiger weil
Putin hat ihn ja auch als Verräter
bezeichnet also in solchen
Kriegssituationen bei Auffahrt steht ja
eigentlich dann Todesstrafe errichte
warum wie kann man das erklären dass
dann das ist eine Straffreiheit gibt
naja Putin hat es ja selbst erklärt
damit dass er gesagt hat am Ende
beigedreht er wollte also wir selbst
sagte keine russisches Blut vergießen
zum einen zum anderen hat den ja
anerkannt dass die Wagner Truppe Großes
geleistet habe im Ukraine Krieg
vermutlich aber meinte auch weltweit
aber hier geht es jetzt zunächst mal um
die Ukraine und dass man im Grunde
genommen solche Kämpfer die ja für das
russische wohl gekämpft haben natürlich
begnadigen müssen weil sie ja letztlich
ihrem Irrtum eingesehen haben und dann
war halt das erzählt sozusagen der
Ausweg aber was natürlich über bleibt
ist doch die Drohung dass man Verräter
bestrafen werde und am Ende sind sie
davon gekommen jedenfalls vorläufig sind
ja noch am Tag drei nach dem watch oder
dieser kleinen militäraufstand und dann
müssen wir erstmal sehen was daraus wird
das heißt sie können sich auch
vorstellen das bringt oder Sie stellen
können noch nicht so sicher ist
nein also so sicher ist er nicht auf der
anderen Seite stellt man sich natürlich
schon die Frage wer soll denn dieses
große Wagner Unternehmen weil wir haben
ja gerade darüber gesprochen dass das
weltweit im Einsatz ist aber vor allen
Dingen in der Ukraine eine ganz
wesentliche kämpferrolle gespielt hat
wer soll das denn in Zukunft führen soll
pregorian jetzt aus Belarus sozusagen
heraus verdeckt für was passiert
eigentlich mit seinen unterkommandeuren
er hat ja nur eine ganze Reihe von
offiziell ich meine das ist eine
militärstruktur die besteht aus
Einheiten aus Kompanien Bataillon und
Pregarten alle haben natürlich und die
Frage ist was passiert mit denen die
russischen Streitkräfte können diese
Gruppe ja nicht einzeln integrieren das
würde ja Monate dauern das würde das
völlige zerschlagen bedeuten das heißt
wenn Sie das tun dann müssen sie ganze
Einheiten und Verbände so übernehmen wie
sie über Menschen operiert sind damit
Sie in kurzer Zeit wieder in den Einsatz
kommt das sind Fragen die sich stellen
und wenn solche Verbände in Weißrussland
oft und dann frage ich mich schon ob
Luca schenke dann seiner Seite sein kann
was dir da kein Eigenleben führen und am
Ende ein ähnlicher Marsch auf Mensch
stattfindet oder dass sie ganz beidrehen
und in Richtung Süden marschieren auch
das ist ja dann nicht ganz aussprechen
wir gleich nochmal über lukaschen kurzen
Moment noch mal bei Putin was das
bedeutet
von wie viel tausend Soldaten gehen wir
eigentlich aus bei dieser wagner-gruppe
wenn man Welt wenn die weltweit ja auch
so agieren es gibt sehr unterschiedliche
Schätzungen die bis zu 50.000 Mann
reichen Annahmen von 25.000 gesprochen
ich habe mal eine Datenbank gesehen die
kurz vor Kriegsbeginn von dem
ukrainischen Geheimdienst SPU erstellt
worden ist also die hatten
offensichtlich so Zugang zu und liegt da
waren etwas weniger als 5000 Namen drin
ähm das ist glaube ich so der Kern auch
der Truppe gewesen sie haben mir immer
zwischendrin auch rekutiert und dann
gibt's sehr viele gefallene dann gibt es
auch Rotationen also
wer da zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt
sozusagen zum aktiven Bestand gehört und
wirklich an der Front kämpft das ist
schwer zu sagen zumal es auch zwischen
verschiedenen
Militärfirmen
hin und hergeht also manche die haben
zeitweilig dann eben bei Wagner gekämpft
und die haben bei
Anti Terror Orell redude und Patch und
also allen möglichen anderen Gruppen die
sind nicht verheiratet auf Dauer
sozusagen mit der wagnergruppe also da
gibt es auch hin und her weswegen man
das immer nur für einen bestimmten
Zeitpunkt aus schätzen kann wie viele da
gerade sozusagen unter Waffen stehen und
wirklich aktiv sind
vielleicht eine kleine Anmerkung dazu
ich glaube wir fokussieren uns wirklich
sehr stark darauf welche militärischen
oder andere Kapazitäten hat aber das
Wichtigste aus dem Samstag für Putins
Regime ist eigentlich nicht selbst das
wichtigste ist jetzt haben die
russischen Eliten gesehen dass einiges
erlaubt ist was noch vor einigen Tagen
absolut undenkbar war das war diesmal
brigoche in erlaubt aber wer weiß was
danach kommt der weiß was noch erlaubt
wird und für solche Regime wie Putin
genau der Punkt wo die Eliten sich
Gedanken machen was sie eigentlich so so
leisten können ist unglaublicher Punkt
der destabilität das wäre auch meine
Frau Frau da mit sie der der russische
Sicherheitsapparat konnte letztendlich
Wagner wenig entgegensetzen fühlten sie
werden sich jetzt andere Gegenspieler
Kritiker Putins aufgefordert fühlen auch
ja den den Chef da in Frage zu stellen
das kann gut sein ich würde das nicht
ausschließen jetzt hat heute Putin ein
paar Schritte bekannt gegeben um sowas
zu verhindern also zum Beispiel die
rossquartier seine Präsidentengarde die
ihm persönlich untersteht die hat schon
Waffen die soll jetzt Panzer dazu
bekommen das heißt deren Kompetenzen
werden ausgeweitet man sieht also dass
Putin noch mal die Möglichkeiten sich
selber zu schützen und zu verteidigen
noch mal vergrößert es kann auch sein
dass es weitere Repressionen geben wird
zum Beispiel noch mal weitere
Internetsperren vielleicht ist es mit
der Freiheit von telegram dann doch
irgendwann vorbei solche Sachen da muss
man schauen aber das hat ja alles auch
nicht mit
angefangen ich erinnere an am Samstag
eben schon seit ja 15 Jahren oder so
seine hat also seine Leibgarde mit auch
zigtausenden Kämpfern und dem eben schon
in Tschetschenien Dinge erlaubt waren
schon seit längerem die völlig gegen die
Gesetze und gegen die russische
Verfassung verstoßen und da fragte man
sich manchmal auch schon ob da nicht der
Schwanz mit dem Hund wedelt weil in
Wirklichkeit eben Kardio auf so viele
Freiheiten hatte und jetzt gibt es
interessanterweise oder gab es gestern
auch in russischen
Boulevardzeitungen schon das Thema
Gewaltmonopol des Staates also das
scheint doch einen Thema zu sein dass
wieder herzustellen ob das jetzt Putin
wiederum noch gelingt in dieser Phase wo
eben der Kampf um die Ressourcen sich
zuspitzt und die Oligarchen die sich
eben private Sicherheitsdienste oder
paramilitärische Truppen leisten können
auch an Vermögen verlieren und
möglicherweise extra aufrüsten um eben
im Zweifelsfall ihr Vermögen verteidigen
zu können also ob da Putin noch alles
und dann im Griff haben wird das ist
meiner Meinung nach offen sehen Sie denn
da als möglichen
Kritiker Putins der ihm da auch wirklich
gefährlich werden könnte und wie steht
es um um den Chef ist Sicherheitsrat
ffb-chef national gerade also seinen
ganzen Sicherheitsapparat
ja alle diese Führer Befehlshaber
Kommandeure dieser Sicherheitsapparat
Verbände werden sich Ihre Gedanken
machen sie werden natürlich abwägen
müssen mit wem sie es dann zu tun haben
aber noch mal um einen auf einen Satz
zurückzukommen den sie gerade gemacht
haben Frau plettmann der
Sicherheitsapparat habe dem wenig
entgegensetzen können am Samstag ich
glaube dass das nicht so ist die waren
vielleicht überrascht man fragt sich
warum in Bürgermeister oder in
Restaurant kein Widerstand geleistet
worden ist ich weiß aber nicht ob die
Lage schon so klar war und diese Zeit
das andere sie haben die Präsidenten
Garde gerade genannt das ist ein sehr
starker Verband der über 40.000 Teil
also Soldaten hat dazu kommt die ganze
national gerade in Deutschland sehr
starker Verband ist da passiert man
früher Truppen der inneren Sicherheit
auch das sind Tropfen auf die man
schauen muss und das sind riesen Stärken
also da kann ein selbständige wirklich 5
dann hatte oder auch weniger da hätte
sie am Ende gar keine Chance gehabt die
Frage ist wann kam es zu dem Zeitpunkt
wo dann tatsächlich auch der der Gegner
Artillerie aufgefahren hat und es zu
kämpfen hätte kommen können und ich
glaube das war auch der Moment wo
pregorian dann peigedreht ist und um
wusste dass das gar keinen Sinn mehr hat
die Frage ist aber doch nur würde ich
sie auch noch mal ganz gerne mal wie
sehr kann Putin sicher sein dass die der
sein Sicherheitsapparat hinter ihm steht
also wie sehr wenn der Ukraine Krieg
weiter nicht so verläuft wie er das hier
nun ursprünglich geplant hat das war für
mich auch die größte Überraschung also
wenn ja das brigotten die Grenzen
ausgetestet hat sondern wie weit er sie
aus testen konnte und das ist da bei der
Einnahme dieses dieser Kommandozentrale
in Roßdorf am donnern überhaupt kein
Widerstand gegeben hat das ist so
Offiziere gab die in sozialen Medien
geäußert haben ja also wir haben noch
eine gut zusammengearbeitet und jetzt
muss man eben unterschiedliche Lösung
finden also es gab da nicht von den
Offizieren höheren auch irgendwie
Äußerungen wir müssen jetzt diesen
Aufstand niederschlagen sondern eher
sagen wir billigende hinnenarme bis hin
zu Sympathiebekundungen und das hätte
mich ein putenstelle sehr beunruhigt ich
glaube was hier deutlich geworden ist
ist dass es zwischen den regulären und
den irregulären Niesen richtig klare
Abstimmung gab also man hat so informell
regiert die sind enormes
institutionalisierungsdefizit das da
deutlich geworden es gibt keine
institutionellen Abläufe das beziehe
basiert auf persönlichen Beziehungen
Anti Partien oder Sympathien das heißt
also letztlich gibt es keine klaren
Abläufe und das macht das System extrem
unvorhersehbar diese Koexistenz von
irregulären bewaffneten Gruppen die
quasi außerhalb des Gesetzes operieren
können und und wo sind
zauberlehrlingseffekt da ist die fühlen
sich plötzlich autonomen die an Lizenz
zum Töten die haben eine Lizenz zu
machen was sie wollen und also das ist
daran aufgebrochen ich glaube es ist
auch aufgebrochen dass die Kriegsziele
nicht mehr
Konsens sind also das maximale würde
aber ja nicht dazu führen dass man jetzt
aus der Ukraine wir werden
falschnachrichten hier werden irgendwie
Nachrichten über über Begrüßung der
Bevölkerung in den besetzten Gebieten
und so weiter das ist alles Fake News zu
deutsch er hat deutlich klar gemacht die
Kriegsziele die wir deklariert haben
können nicht mehr erreicht werden und
dafür wird er beim Militär ist auch
Sympathien gehabt haben wir müssen also
minimalere Kriegsziele verfolgen
wichtig finde Entschuldigung also
privatin ist aufgetreten wie nahweil nee
das erste Mal dass er eigentlich diese
ganze
korruptionsagenta die Oligarchen Kritik
auf die Bühne gehoben hat und das waren
in dem Sinne Kombination zwischen dieser
militärischen Kritik und gleichzeitig
wir haben eine verrottete verfettete
sozusagen so ungewöhnlicher das Putin in
mir jetzt Straffreiheit gibt wenn auch
das ist neu weil Putin hat in der
Vergangenheit alle Gegner diese
liquidiert und das ist ein Zeichen der
Schwäche dass er diesmal zumindest nicht
sofort konnte sondern dass er letztlich
sich auf einem vielleicht macht
teilungsdeal oder so einlassen musste
auf jeden Fall
aber das muss aber auch Putin reagiert
auf Druck das heißt für den Krieg ist
das auch relevant meine Frage geben was
denken Sie was bedeutet diese Ereignisse
für den Krieg in der Ukraine also
zunächst mal haben wir keine konkreten
Effekte gesehen wenn wir auf die
Entwicklung in der letzten Tage geschaut
haben die Front hält es ist auch bekannt
dass prekorschen bei der Einnahme von
Militärstützpunkten etwa von
flugwaffenbasen trotzdem die Angriffe
gegen die Ukraine zugelassen hat sich
nicht dagegen gewehrt hat und das ist
eigentlich der Punkt bei dem ich
vielleicht etwas anderer Meinung sind
als sie
hat tatsächlich behauptet der Krieg war
eine falsche Entscheidung hat ganz klar
gesagt
Gregorian hat die enorme Korruption in
der russischen Militärführung kritisiert
aber die schlussfolgen die daraus Trikot
schon gezogen hat war eine ganz andere
sind aber inizit seine schlussfolgung
war es war ein falscher Krieg aber den
höchsten wir trotzdem gewinnen weil wir
den schon angefangen haben und aus
dieser Sicht würde ich wirklich zwischen
zwei verschiedenen Aspekten
unterscheiden zum einen den inneren
Machtkämpfen in Russland und zum anderen
der Unterstützung für den Krieg und da
haben wir bis jetzt in den russischen
Eliten zumindest
keine aktiven Stimmen gehört die sich
klar gegen den Krieg oder so unklar
gegen den Krieg positioniert haben viele
die aber noch radikale Vorgehensweise
fordern verdammt was würden Sie denn
sagen was ich daran ändern würde da wird
sich was ändern was den Krieg in der
Ukraine betrifft also der Gedanke dass
und von manchen kannst du wirklich auch
verhaltene Sympathien für going also
denken wir ankowski zum Beispiel der ja
so Unterstützung
aufgerufen hat bzw gesagt hat wir müssen
das jetzt erstmal unterstützen weil
alles was Gewalt mäßig sich gegen dieses
System richtet oder dieses Regime
richtet gut ist
also wir sollten uns nicht der Hoffnung
hingeben dass da irgendwas irgendein
Akteur der wesentlichen Akteure diesen
Krieg beenden wollte gegen die Ukraine
das ist nicht so ich wollte gerne noch
was sagen zu dem korruptionsgedanken das
hat Gregorian wirklich geschickt gemacht
er hat sich ja seit Monaten
positioniert als wir hier unten gegen
die da oben die Generäle deren oder die
Generäle sind ja bei ihm noch eher
angesehen aber die Funktionäre und deren
Kinder die eben ihre YouTube-Videos
aufnehmen und sich das gut gehen lassen
und die Bosse sitzen in ihren getäfelten
marktoni Büros und so weiter das ist so
ein ganz klares Bild das kommt natürlich
unheimlich gut an bei der Bevölkerung
und daraus wurde ja auch geschlossen
dass für politische Ambitionen habe
womit ich nicht konform gehe das glaube
ich tatsächlich nicht aber mich hat sehr
sehr gewundert dann tatsächlich diese
Aussage diese klare Aussage mit der
Begründung für den Krieg dass das alles
sei und der Don Bass der wurde gar nicht
bombardiert in den letzten acht Jahren
von der Ukraine das sein alles
vorgeschobene Gründe
ja ich glaube auch deswegen glaube ich
auch dass das von ihm auch vielleicht
eine
rhetorische rhetorische Ausfall war um
einfach Scheu guter noch mal ans Wein zu
pinkeln um ihm genau das noch mal
vorzuwerfen dann Sinn ergibt es
eigentlich nicht diesen Krieg die ganze
Zeit unterstützt und würde ihn auch
weiter unterstützen wie sehen Sie das
denn jetzt konkret wird sich dann was
ändern wenn die Wagner Truppen da nicht
mehr so aktiv mit Kämpfen in der Ukraine
was bedeutet das für das Land ja
zunächst einmal muss man ja sagen ich
stelle also durchaus zu dass er sich
gegen die Korrektion gewandt hat dass er
sich so ein bisschen diese sogenannte
Frontschweine Sprache an
das lassen sich praktisch angegliedert
hat an die frontgruppe er hat ein
Sprachrohr abgegeben für die
Unzufriedenheit die es dort gab und hat
seine Ziele gefunden und Gerasdorf aber
er hat natürlich und da stelle ich eben
nicht zu er hat in den letzten Monaten
sich durchaus taktisch und auch operativ
abgestimmt mit der örtlichen oder
regionalen Militärführung er hat ja
nichts getan was die Operation in Frage
gestellt hat er hat den bachmut in
Abstimmung mit den Fallschirmjägern die
andere an den Flanken kämpft gekämpft
haben sich abgestimmt er hat die
Straßenkämpfe dort geführt und hat
natürlich den Eindruck erwecken wollen
als ob er da ein selbstständigen Krieg
führe das hat er aber nicht getan das
ist eine ein falscher ein Wort er war
völlig eingegliedert in die operative
Führung und seine Ziele waren klar er
wollte die Unabhängigkeit seiner Gruppe
bewahren und er hat natürlich auch
darauf gedrungen dass seine Erfolge
entsprechend gewürdigt werden und das
wenn er Verluste hatte man auch ein
Blitzableiter fanden nämlich die Militär
für uns also nicht ausreichend
unterstützt habe wo die Munition fehlte
und so weiter das am Ende dann über die
rote Linie gegangen ist und auch den
Krieg als Ganzes sozusagen von der
Begründung her in Frage gestellt hat ich
weiß nicht ob das so ein Plan war oder
ein Ausrutscher ein rhetorischer
Ausrutscher am Ende jedenfalls hatte
damit natürlich Putin herausgefordert
aber das war vielleicht gar nicht sein
eigentliches Ziel jetzt zu der Frage was
passiert also es hängt ja sehr stark
davon ab wie viel Truppe man annimmt für
diese wagnergruppe wie wir schon selbst
sprach von 25
000 in der Ukraine bzw in Russland es
gibt Berichte von amerikanischen und
britischen Geheimdiensten die weiter
darüber hinausgehen aber nehmen wir mal
das an dann stellt Wagen na ja doch
immerhin ein großen Prozentsatz der
russischen Gruppen da nämlich bis zu
zehn Prozent der russischen Gruppen die
im Kampfeinsatz sind ich meine nicht der
gesamten russischen Streitkräfte sondern
derjenigen die im Kampf einsetzen in der
Ukraine sind und deswegen wird es auf
lange Sicht natürlich ein Einfluss geben
derzeit nicht bei strukturell ist Wagner
ja aus diesem Raum bachmut ohnehin
abgezogen es ist er ist ersetzt worden
durch reguläre Gruppen aber irgendwann
werden Reserven natürlich fehlen und ich
gehe davon aus dass man wagnertruppen
als Verbände als Einheiten in die
russischen Streitkräfte integriert zur
fernsehgausforderung
okay schauen wir noch mal jetzt auf
Belarus wenn wir sagen Gregorian ist
jetzt in Belarus nach allem was wir
wissen
Lukaschenko der jetzt Putin hilft der
sagt wir nehmen den auf was bedeutet
denn das was bedeutet das für
Lukaschenko eine ganz große Stärkung
oder na ja ob es eine wirklich ganz
große Stärkung ist es völlig unklar
lukaschenisiert sich jetzt natürlich als
der große
Retter von Russland also in seiner
letzten Rede hat ja sogar angedeutet
dass er bereit wäre Moskau zu
verteidigen mit seinen Truppen ebenso
wie ist 41 passiert ist wir wissen aber
es Lukaschenko durchaus gewisse
Neigung zu solche Art von Rhetorik hat
rein praktisch gesehen es ist für uns
völlig unklar obliga schenkrad überhaupt
unabhängig war oder einfach ein
Sprachrohr war in der Kommunikation wo
die Fronten verhärtet waren und Putin
selbst keine Weise mit Pregarten
kommunizieren wollte es ist völlig
unklar wie viele Wagner Leute jetzt nach
Belarus auswandern werden und dort
bleiben werden wir haben ja zu Recht
Afrika genannt wo Wagner durchaus starke
Positionen hat und das ist völlig unklar
was jetzt in Belarus machen wird also
ich würde jetzt von keiner Stärkung
sprechen ja aber man hat ja auch ab dem
7 juli sind jetzt wieder
Atomwaffen in Belarus werden wieder
stationiert oder zumindest es kann da
Raketen die man bestücken kann mit Atom
springen was also wie stark braucht
Putin belleres oder nutzt er das oder
gibt's dann auch eine Gefahr das sagen
ja auch Menschen das halt eben dann
Belarus doch eine aktive Rolle in diesem
Krieg noch mal spielt
hat
eigene Logistik oder sag mal Flughäfen
da auch bereitgestellt und und das ist
auch von einem dem Territorium
ausgeschlossen worden aber die wollten
nicht mit eigenen Bodentruppen
involviert sein und wenn jetzt Wagner
von selber zeigen eine zweite Front
aufmacht nehmen neben der Don bassfront
dann wurde es ja zum unmittelbaren
Kriegsbeteiligten bisher wollte das
verhindern
vor drei Jahren als Lukaschenko die
Wahlen fälschte hat er mehrere Wagner
läutet ihre Dutzend sogar gefangen
nehmen lassen weil sie angeblich sich an
einem Putschversuch gegen Lukaschenko
beteiligt sind unsere hat diese
Geschichte vom Wochenende sogar einen
Vorgeschichte vor ziemlich exakt drei
Jahren in Belarus also das
Vertrauensverhältnis zwischen den beiden
ist auch nicht ausgeprägt
die große Frage ist die Richter auch
angesprochen hat wird Wagner überleben
gestern zum Beispiel habe ich geguckt
die Webseite von Wagner ist geschlossen
worden rauskommen Natur also die
Aufsichtsbehörde hat also die ganzen
Kanäle geschlossen die können über
telegram noch kommunizieren aber das
waren deutlicher Ankündigung überall in
der Stadt in St Petersburg Moskau sind
die reklamische Schilder für Wagner
eingezogen sofort eingezogen worden das
heißt also man kann mit einigen Verträge
abschließen sie vielleicht auch in
andere Firmen integrieren
ob sie jetzt zum Beispiel Mali
Zentralafrikanische Republik Syrien
Libyen so schnell ersetzbar sind große
Frage aber sie sind auch in da sind sie
ursprünglich aus einer anderen Gruppe
nämlich der Moralen Gruppe
hervorgegangen also es hat auch im Laufe
der Zeit immer solche Transformationen
von solchen Militärfirmen gegeben man
benennt die um und zu dem rigorian und
da Imperium gehören so viele andere
Firmen
Fasten Dutzend weiterer firmenexport
importfirmen goldfirmen und so weiter
also man kann da auch mit so einer
Transformation rechnen grundsätzlich
glaube ich das Interesse von Lukaschenko
in den Krieg aktiv einzugreifen ist
begrenzt Frau damit die würden sie es
beurteilen weil es gibt ja auch so
theoretische
ja ich wollte da also wir wollen erst
Braut bauen nee machen sie dann jetzt
kurz dann machen wir machen wir es so
rum weil sie haben den schlechteren Part
weil ja bitte weil sie sagten
dass Belarus ja sich nicht am Krieg
beteiligen will das ist natürlich schon
mal richtig auf der anderen Seite ist zu
Kriegsbeginn also im Februar letzten
Jahres gab es einen Angriff aus
weißrussischen Gebiet auf hier mit
russischen Truppen und mit Artillerie
und raketenstellungen in Weißrussland
und die haben dann auch auf ukrainische
Stellung gefeuert insofern fragt man
sich natürlich wie weit kann man
eigentlich gehen und dann immer noch
behaupten man soll nicht am Krieg
beteiligt dass ich so ein Szenario
wiederholen könnte würde ich jetzt nicht
ausschließen ob Wagen dazu geeignet ist
ist eine ganz andere Frage aber meiner
hat ja schon gesagt dass ist eine es
gibt immer die Möglichkeit solche Firmen
um zu benennen die Verbände im Grunde
genommen geschlossen zu lassen und sie
irgendwo anders zu integrieren die Frage
ist ja am Ende
so sieht das mit der Führung aus und
zwar nicht nur mit dem Chef des
Unternehmens also pregorian sondern auch
mit anderen die auch wichtige Position
habe ich denke mal an metrische oder
andere die ja was ich auch die Frage
stellt was wird aus denen in Zukunft
werden sie das Imperium weiterführen
oder Teile davon und selbstverständlich
kann man das nicht aufgeben dafür haben
sie viel zu wichtige Funktionen wie viel
Rückhalt hat denn oder was würden Sie
sagen so in den nächsten Wochen was kann
sich auch in der russischen Gesellschaft
da ändern und wie war das so ein
Ereignis das vielleicht der eine oder
andere Russland anders denkt über diesen
Krieg oder über Belarus oder ist es geht
es völlig vorbei in der vielen Menschen
ich glaube an vielen geht's vorbei wenn
wir jetzt mal von der Strecke Rasthof
Moskwa Moskau absehen wo eben die
Kolonnen lang gefahren sind und auch
westlich davon
was ich vorhin sagte wir sollten es
nicht überschätzen mit dieser Mitteilung
von und dieser dieser Wutrede von
prigoshi in der sich eben gegen den
Krieg insgesamt da gewandt hat wir
wissen gar nicht wie viele Menschen das
überhaupt erreicht wir haben heute einen
immenses aufgebaut und auch schon am
Sonntagabend an Propaganda gesehen
wo eben diese ganze Sache als glückliche
Wendung für den cremel und Putin
verkauft wird als Möglichkeit noch mal
zu beweisen dass wir eben stark sind und
den dollsten Herausforderungen
widerstehen es wird ja auch schon gesagt
dass diese ganze Sache für ihn
eigentlich ein komplettes Westens
gewesen sein das war absehbar dass
dieses narrativ irgendwann kommt und es
gibt eben sehr viele Menschen die ja den
die zu allem Ja sagen was ihnen von oben
präsentiert wird und diejenigen die
ohnehin gegen den Krieg eingestellt sind
und die sich bestätigt fühlen könnten
durch diese Äußerung von ähm die sehen
ohnehin nicht fern und die insofern sind
sind aber auch atomisiert und nicht in
der Lage sich zu verbinden in die
Gesellschaft ist sehr sehr atomisiert
und die Leute sind auf sich allein
gestellt weil sie den Westen gerade auch
angesprochen haben die westlichen
Reaktionen am Wochenende waren ja sehr
zurückhaltend sagen wir alle haben
miteinander telefoniert beiden macron
Scholz haben telefoniert aber haben sich
sehr zurückgehalten Herr Lippmann wie
sehr wie wichtig ist das dass sich der
Westen da zurückhält oder sollte es dann
eine andere Reaktion gehen für mich war
die Zurückhaltung wirklich das Einzige
was man in dieser Situation überhaupt
machen konnte erstens ist es völlig
unklar warum ist es passiert und ich
stimme natürlich so dass es nicht die
Intention von war Putin herauszufordern
das heißt es geht um Macht Kämpfe um den
throm herum und warum muss ich da der
Westen überhaupt einen mischen und das
zweite ist egal was der Westen dazu
gesagt hätte das wäre gewollte Futter
für russische dann würde man sofort das
ausnutzen und viel mehr es ist jetzt
passiert das ist alles vom Besten
organisiert war
Dinge die Aussage dass die
amerikanischen
Dienste schon vor einiger Zeit gewusst
haben dass sowas möglich ist wurde schon
von Propaganda benutzt als Beweis ist
von denen inszeniert wurde stellen sich
mal vor ist käme mehr also das ist das
einzige was da bleibt aber eine Mann
grüner ist das muss dieses Wochenende
Anlass sein um sich noch mal vom Westen
aus darauf einzustellen was passieren
könnte wenn Putins Regime doch fällt
absolut ich bin der Ansicht wir brauchen
bessere Nachrichtendienste die nicht den
Nachrichten hinterherlaufen wo man dann
das Gefühl hat jetzt fängt der BND auch
an zu googeln und dann wenn die
Ergebnisse 2 Stunden später den
Bundeskanzleramt mitgeteilt also ich bin
früher informiert worden als
offensichtlich des Bundeskanzleramt
von Journalisten die gefragt haben wie
ich das einschätze also die die schon
Berichte hatten oder Telegramm Kanäle
und so weiter verfolgt haben das zweite
wir müssen uns von der Haltung befreien
lieber einen stabilen Autokraten Putin
an der Macht als jetzt die die Zeit der
Wirren und der Anarchie weil letztlich
müssen wir uns sagen diese Situation
kommen durch das System zustande der
Krieg ist durch die orthokratie durch
die Diktatur in Russland zustande
gekommen auch diese Art von
informellem regieren die das möglich
machte es ist ein Resultat dieses
Regimes das heißt also es fallen sofort
wieder die Instinkte wie zur Spätphase
der Sowjetunion an also lieber einen ähm
sozusagen ein autoritärisches Regime
dass das also äh den Zerfall
russlandsauffällt ich glaube wir müssen
uns Gedanken machen über Szenarien wie
das aufgehen kann und welche
Sollbruchstellen da sind und das ist
eine Sollbruchstelle aber es gibt noch
eine reiche andere und die werden
irgendwann politisiert und irgendwann
wird diese eliteneinheit aufbrechen das
heißt wir müssen uns über mögliche
Szenarien nach putingedanken machen und
da gibt es verschiedene denkbare das
eine ist sozusagen Usbekistan oder
Kasachstan das andere ist aber auch das
eine aus den Sicherheitsapparaten des
übernimmt und so weiter also sind nicht
alles Szenarien da und das
gorbatschow-szenario ist das
unwahrscheinlichste und trotzdem müssen
wir uns darauf einstellen was machen wir
eigentlich in jedem Fall
dass jemand kommen ist und das sozusagen
Reformer und pro westlich und pro Europa
und das war jetzt ein Fehler sich da
abzugrenzen und so weiter und wir haben
keine Vorstellung davon wie wir damit
umgehen sollten
damit worauf sollte man sich ein oder
was wäre wichtig jetzt vom Westen aus
sich zu also wenn man nach Russland
schaut welche Strategie müsste man da
irgendwie haben
ich denke zu dieser Sollbruchstelle
gehört auch ob Russland
auseinanderfallen könnte ich sehe das
erstmal noch nicht aber das ist durchaus
ein Szenario und das wird sehr aktiv von
den russischen Exilanten diskutiert ob
das eintreten wird und da muss ich der
Westen oder das Ausland muss sich
überlegen wie sie eigentlich dazu stehen
also will man jetzt in Russland um jeden
Preis in dieser Form erhalten oder muss
man vielleicht auch sich darauf
einstellen oder ist also eine Haltung
dazu nicht nur einstellen sondern wie
wird man das finden wenn Russland
auseinanderbrechen sollte und dann ist
natürlich noch eine ganz wichtige Frage
wie hält man Kontakt zur
Zivilbevölkerung wenn es nicht im Land
geht dann aber zu denen die im Ausland
sind und die möglicherweise irgendwann
zu irgendein bestimmten Zeitpunkt mal
ein Russland mit aufbauen könnten dass
eben nicht Anti westlich sein wird
sondern
wirklicherweise Entferner Zukunft
demokratisch aber zumindest nicht
aggressiv ich glaube vorhin gesagt Putin
reagiert auch oder hat auf Druck
reagiert er Richter kann denn jetzt eine
Folge von diesem Wochenende sein für den
besten zu sagen ja wir müssen auf wir
müssen auch einen Druck erhöhen oder ist
dadurch die Möglichkeit einer Eskalation
dieses Krieges noch viel greifbarer
die auch unsere Sicherheitslage bedroht
also
der Ukraine Krieg ist schlimm genug aber
es gäbe ja noch Schlimmeres Szenario
also eine Eskalation das sollte man im
Auge behalten ich würde jetzt zunächst
mal Herrn Heinemann wieder sprechen was
er wusste und was der Bundeskanzler
wusste oder was der
Bundesnachrichtendienst wusste ist der
Öffentlichkeit nicht zugänglich und da
würde ich jetzt vor Stein Thesen etwas
lernen das zweite ist ich würde auch
diesen ganzen Vorgang etwas tiefer
hängen ähm es ist ein Ergebnis gewesen
dass das macht Monopol nicht eindeutig
beim Staat liegt und das tut in
versuchte mit verschiedenen
mächtegruppen zu spielen und er hat
jetzt gesehen welche Gefahren das Berg
und der wird sicherlich auch seinen
Lehrern daraus ziehen ob das schon der
Anfang vom Ende des Regens ist das ist
sicherlich das wird in der Exil
Gemeinschaft diskutiert ich kann im
Moment aber innerhalb Russlands eine
wirkliche elitenspaltung allenfalls in
der Frage ob der Krieg richtig geführt
wird aber nicht dass der Krieg generell
falsch ist das ich glaube die die
Ergebnisse die operativen Ergebnisse der
Kriegsführung die könnten dann wirklich
einen Einfluss haben auf das Denken der
Eliten so wie es brigoshi teilweise
jetzt schon kundgetan hat der andere
Punkt ist das hatten sie vorhin so im
Vorbeigehen gesagt Frau blättmann die
Atomwaffen in Weißrussland die dort
stationiert worden sind das hat
natürlich mit lukaschen erstmal herzlich
wenig zu tun hier ist er doch eher ein
Wasser gewesen diese Waffen bleiben
natürlich unter der zentralen oberheit
der russischen Militärführung und das
Präsidenten es geht hier nur darum dass
man diese Mittel die dafür in zum
Einsatz kommen könnten also es kann aber
Raketen oder auch Flugzeuge die
ungerüstet werden dort vorbereitet und
dass man die Waffen in zentralen Lagern
behält dürfte also unstrittig sein vor
diesem Hintergrund ist das Szen das hier
gerade diskutiert worden ist also eine
staatszerfalls eigentlich ein
ungemütliches Szenario denn wir haben es
zu tun mit einer macht die über 6.000
Atomwaffen verfügt das sollte man auch
nicht herbeiräten dass das ein
wünschbares Szenario wäre ich würde an
der Stelle auch in einem Mann
widersprechen der Westen hat richtig
gehandelt er hat nämlich versucht genau
das zu vermeiden was man dann als
Propaganda natürlich verwenden kann das
ganze von außen organisiert war
ausgesprochen klar geworden dass das
nicht der Fall war und das war wir sind
gespannt wie das weitergeht natürlich
noch weiter wir werden das natürlich
weiter verfolgen am Donnerstag wenn er
wieder in der Phönix Runde an lässt sich
das EU-Gipfels auch noch mal darauf
schauen dann auch nicht normal darauf
auf die Rolle des Westens dann auch noch
mal schauen vielen Dank Frau Dornburg
Herr Richter
und Herr Lippmann vielen dank ihnen fürs
zuschauen morgen schauen wir mal
innenpolitisch genauer hin der erste AFD
Landrat auf der Suche nach Ursachen
fragen wir dann und den Tag den
moderiert jetzt Konstanz geht bis dann
[Musik]